c'era pietro ieri che sarà strillando
venerdì 13 allora ho deciso di giocare
con lui per romperli un po le balle
questo è il risultato macché maglietta
giallo di merda c'hai non ce l'ho io se
creativi non sono quello notti nella
vita reale via la testa come ti permetti
le teche anno e altro lato c'è una tale
carica di bambini di punti per non c'era
il tavolo ma sai che stai dentro quando
l'avevo mai vista dell'uscita che
neanche ma hanno aggiornato il suo gioco
nel mentre non era mai uscito dall'acqua
non è vero oggi ero qua fa il suv poi si
inseriscono tav ha istruito prima
bastardi mani fuori con che cattivi come
avevano allora non riusciva a farti gli
altri dati fuori tifariti sta facendo
basta perché rifare segnare morse con la
luce perché sono di esso segnare morpher
[ __ ] lo dirà lesbica ma chi è
questo che voglio è stato quello è
bellissimo mi suono niente niente
veramente bene una bella persona togliti
che dopo il cassetto e problemi di uomo
a donna le chiavi o tra tre chiavi
madonna quanto è bello con l'uomo che ti
segue tutti innamorato e lo vedo basta
odio ha lasciato un coltello fortissimo
che sono quanto meno in carriera gioco
perché si è entrato in casa scavalcando
bene l'altra no
chi cazzo è sbagliato ma di cui un
giorno farà star da jason 21 viola o
medica sono i sindaci ha detto non mi
brucia moto viabilità stavo per mourinho
sbarra ci aspetta aspetta aspetta che è
stato che io ho una pistola gli sparo
proprio scappi mai la parola ci vai con
la sera poi scappa scappa scappa scappa
scavi serio e mi segue cari via viene
conteggiato circa
ma cosa che qua qua sta mettendo alla
batteria sapete io lo chiamo telecamere
per caso anche la tanica che ci abbiamo
tutto subito
minchia che sfiga ci ho sperato prete
che li prova a chiedere in modo
tranquillo sono trovato da tali tanica
aspetta aia palas archiviarlo aggiuntive
da una terza storia che ho picchiato un
a badilate impacciati servire per caso
find that anica bene di vento convinti
lo sa dicono dove veronica organica nota
di casamica baia tra sconto per forza in
fiore veni vidi la barca della barca
l'area ma la marca doveva fare la barca
sotto il segno meno benzina eccoli hanno
invece ci sono sono parlati vedo quanto
cisti in conti stiamo là
occhio non paghi gioco vi ammazzo ti
ammazzo nel mare sono partite senza di
me diamogli e vivi taglio la gola parole
f che deve recuperare un po di patimenti
sopra di sopra questo qua io per più
sarete così arrivando qua che già sono
dietro porca vacca aiuto no non mi
saremo pt enel ti giuro che mio
personaggio ha smesso di correre non li
funzionano più le gambe te lo giuro e
quindi e niente
eccoli ma ci siamo se non si sta
arrivando sono qua se lo faccio qui
sì e no addio a schiacciare non sono qui
per te peccato che vuole morto io voglio
uscire di come sempre io tra i più
morire come si esce da questo stagno e
schifoso puzzolente che però il caso i
livelli io sapevo prima andare alla
macchia noi ha la macchina a mandare
kraft siamo scarsi a questo gioco da 1 a
mille tu lo sia ancora morte o no quanto
sporco di sangue ai fedeli come sto
correndo che se il cammino all'indietro
modo più bello è che le donne non ora
che il cammino così non mi chiedere
perché più di controllo è appena
un'altra persona mi fa piacere
giunto nei giorni scorsi secondo mito di
sistemi jarvis dai dai dai dai
è il problema che cosa facciamo
cerchiamo la barca per scappare ora è
quella barca è la barca in mezzo al
fiume perché mica puoi usarla ti si può
conclusa la luna distrugge darti fa solo
cadere ma nell'undici adesso è appena
morto altra tipo è esatto e non corre
non corre squarciati se arriva gli spari
con il fucile è fortissimo e corriamo
sulla barca ci raggiunge sulla barca ma
se gli spari dovuti giu merda qui perché
è qui e vi da me è qui sotto è qui sotto
eccolo
magari non ci ha visti e mi sta
guardando nel caso siamo ok ok
scegli scendi scendi sparagli però dai
vari tu prendi la barca dispari
spaccatura della banca prima barca che
vedete in foto delle più tempo riserve
[Musica]
dove ci sono dentro al motore marino di
corri soldi soldi soldi costone
[ __ ] a piedi ciao ciao vince e tu
pensa mentalmente sono partiti sabato
io devo salvarmi con salvarmi aiuto
aiuto non ci si salva per andare di
vendere verso verso dall'altra parte ed
attendono sud deve andare come è già
proprio dire andare 6 la marca vecchia e
gli umidi di statura
io tengo pratico temi ottieni lo devo
andare a distruggere l'anello al mondo
islamico che ci sono i quasi 6 quo
parole il primo tempo di scabroso e
scappando poi c'è un po troppo basso e
dei problemi al cervello super sud sud a
nord sud e sulle sue norme donne stupido
nella vita nel cervello proprio è
assurdo tantissimo lenord karanka vasta
l'area nord al nord a sinistra non lo
sono
ok madonna che al sesto gioco brutto
perché sono qui ce ne sono dieci
uccidere è che possiamo citare due set a
uno schermo ci credo
[Musica]
mi faccio io grazie pietro grazie tutto
valuterò enrico grazie pietro ma tutto
il cuore lo dico grazie
ma riesce a prendermi ma cos'è
tanto c'è una camionata di mister b me
succede liberati vive a di viverti è più
volte sono fuggito il tuo sacrificio
e stato grazie l'hai fatto belle virus
hai fatto mezza mappa mantenendo per
amica guardati dal circuito di formula 1
capivo più niente era certo
[Musica]
e a quanto pare la mamma il nuovo giusto
ora che manca possiamo essere la
leggenda una gestione davvero alla spada
si no
inoltre si potrebbe essere
voglio pietro io pietro bastardo
abbastanza basse tanto basta vieni qui
c'è in gioco brutto scherzo allora la
tanica lattaio è la batteria e le chiavi
sì sì vieni qua sono già infatti non
avessero già sulla tangenziale
io a dire cosiddetto pensami che insieme
ci aiutano la peggio no no mi sono
chiuso io voglio punto a loro e basta
interrogazione frega del resto no no no
stanno non mi ci da non incidere
situazione ma se quello sta mettendo la
batteria brutto stronzo mera medico
uccide in testa è che fate
siamo tomorrow morto è bellissimo e
quindi i ragazzi che sarà la sintesi di
ciò che è successo il live spero che
video vi sia piaciuto ho vinto
va bene è vero che ho dovuto sacrificare
un amico a va bene così perché le
persone egocentriche lo fanno spesso
quello che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
ci piace al momento che mi piace anche i
vari social comunista notizia né se non
sapersi siete riusciti vediamo al
prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]